hi
the question i have for you today is
does your aikido work
i've had a lot of hirings who
have objected against me saying that
iwama
aikido is any better than
the hombu dojo i used the word ikikai
before but
we're talking really about what's what
come originally out of the home
dojo and from then on each teacher would
go into the world japanese and foreign
and they would arrive at their own
perception of aikido
and how they could tweak it what they
thought was valuable
how do you teach the students better
really it's a journey of each person
and we mold the students to how we think
the aikido should be
given and taught to the world and when
them students become a certain level
and become teachers their self they
would do the same
so aikido has been evolving
it evolved from her scentsy to
kishimura tower scentsy
tamiki aikido that's a very
interesting one the tamiki one because
to me he he saw a lot of holes in
people doing aikido
and so these people are being taught by
osensei
he's training with them on the mat and
he's seeing hulls
because he's a very educated
martial artist himself
he turned aikido into a sport
and if you see an opening then you can
counter
and you can be the one doing the aikido
on the person who is supposed to be
doing the aikido techniques on you
even after all these years of doing yuan
aikido i still see lots of holes
so this is why i personally keep doing
aikido because i'm trying to fill those
holes in
how do you make it so there isn't a gap
for another martial artist to be able to
get in there
and reverse a technique on you
it may not be the same technique
any while when we call this kaishi was a
kaishi was a reversal technique
somebody may do an icky on you but that
might lead you into a code guys
a niccio but it will
lead you into another technique where
you become
the winner so instead of becoming uk you
become nage
so a lot of aikido is weak
but what is the real main difference if
we're looking at
iwama versus hombu
is the aikido to me they're the same
iwama versus any flowing
style of aikido
i've been watching like many of us
youtube and i see these beautiful
flowing and they are beautiful flowing
by the present doshu his father
and they are the tops they're the ones
that we
we respect and i do respect them
and the current dosha i've met and he's
a real gentleman i like him very much
and i really like his eye you know but
it's not the style i chose
after researching
the problem is i'd like to really talk
about
the differences does your aikido work
and most aikido will not work
because there's too many holes in it i
will be talking in detail
in the future showing as well where
these
weaknesses are in my book i cover
many many of the common weaknesses
doesn't matter what style you do
they're all the techniques that we know
and one particular advanced uh
ikedoka wrote to me and said he'd
trained with everybody
and he couldn't see any difference in
the techniques
whether it be guy hombu
yoshing yes the body postures may be the
same
sorry the diff different but the
techniques are the same
this is where i differ because
if you're going to instruct a person on
how to attack you
then you're already setting up a
choreographed
set of movements if you take it further
and you start telling the
okay how they must
attack you with it the degree of
you must grip me lightly as soon as i
move
you must follow and you must keep
connected to me
and between us it will become harmonious
the two of us will become one
and it will end in a throw or pin
i sense he didn't train this way and he
didn't tease this way
i've been told this by some very old
gentlemen
that have stopped training now but they
did train without scentsy
and they said to me jose said he wanted
100 force they used the word force
but we understand the word force
differently
i think hello i understood by him and
this
was a one particular person was in a
train
back from those sighted senses
it was his wake after his passing
they cremate the body there's a few
bones left
that are picked out by i believe
his son hid here and put in a
case this is my remembrance of it it may
not be accurate
so it was at the wake and after the
weight we were on the train back to
tokyo
and this gentleman said oh sensei said
in tana tahanahanka especially
that you must grip with 100 force
the commitment he had to see
was 100 if it wasn't 100
gripping of one's wrist i sense it would
shout and shout saying this is not good
enough you're not giving 100
so i now know that the difference
between the flowing style
and iwama style what was those senses
original
was that one says
grip with everything you have and the
other says
grip lightly and
follow
many of you will not agree with me but
this is what i believe
and when i've trained with aikikai
people
and the flying styles their grip is
never
excruciating my wrist on my wrist
and i'm not looking at the whites of
their knuckles
now the benefit of this is
if it's all about humbling and trying to
find
the better person within yourself
if you don't grip 100 percent
how will the person trying to do the
technique
tie the hanker in this case know
if they can move you or not if they
cannot move you
they have to humble their self and say
please not so strong
and if they get the poster ease off a
little
then they can try again
if they don't have
if they can't do it then
they have to ask again and slowly this
humbling
makes the person understand
if uk decides oh
they can't move i will ease off
the humbling doesn't come from the right
person and we'll talk more about this
in the future thank you very much for
your time
please comment and subscribe